i'm at my building and i just want to
show you what a shelter room looks like
follow me if you can see
we need codes to get into the building
but not today the door is open so that
anyone who is outside during the attack
can get into the building and into the
shelter room
this is it this is the door it's
massive it's iron it has several locks
here and as you can see also it's
normally locked and all the residents
have the keys
because it's used as storage but again
this is it look at the massive door so
let's go inside
this is the room you can see it's not
big it's like 10 to 12 square meters
and it's been used as i said it's been
used as storage
there's stuff from the residence so what
we have here
is we have a window and it's not like
normal window look at this there is this
iron
curtain which closes
when the siren goes off so you close
this curtain
you close the window and that's it then
you close the door
and there are two ac's for
the air i'm lucky because i have a
shelter room in my own apartment
but those who don't come downstairs when
the siren goes off
and stay here until it's safe again
people bring the emergency bags with
water snacks
power banks and other stuff they might
need in case they have to stay inside
for a long time
you